our state has reached a settlement with
the advertising company mckinsey and
company for its advertising role in the
ongoing
opioid crisis here in nevada state
attorney general aaron ford explained in
a press conference today that he and his
office wanted to hold mackenzie
accountable for its consulting services
to big pharma companies
particularly their advising on how to
maximize profits
and target doctors to get them to
prescribe more opioids
ford says the impact opioids have had on
our state is immense
the devastation caused by the opioid
epidemic is failed by every mother and
father who has lost a child
it's felt by siblings who have lost a
sister or a brother
it's felt by friends and colleagues who
lost one of their own
and obviously it's felt by those still
suffering from an opioid addiction
ford chose to pursue separate legal
action against the company as he felt
our state deserve
more than what we would have received in
a multi-state settlement so from that
nevada did receive 45 million dollars
ford says he's proud that mckinsey
stepped forward to cooperate
and says that holding companies
responsible is the first step in
combating the ongoing crisis